[Applause]
hey everyone and welcome to another
episode of the outdoor boys YouTube
channel today we're going to be
restoring this folding bike now this
folding bike has a little bit of a
sentimental history for me my wife and I
bought a pair of these in 2003 in
preparation for one of our trips to
Japan and these are folding bikes they
fold up and you can fit him into a bag
and take them on an airplane and stuff
so we took a pair of these to Japan and
then use them to ride all over the
country and it's just a fun little bike
we got off the internet you know 15
years ago and it is so beat-up we're
gonna restore this thing and just really
make it look awesome try to bring it
back so that's not like a fun project oh
yeah all right guys let's survey the
damage a little bit first you can see
the seat is garbage here it's all
mildewy and nasty and torn the whole
steering stem is just solid rust
gearshift got some problems bells all
rusty yeah both tires are completely
flat this is the the hinge in the main
frame that allows it to fold into two
pieces and that is that is stuck got
more rust lots of rust kickstand and the
rear brakes all rusty pedals panels are
rusted up
sprockets got some serious serious rust
right there uh-huh there we go
oh it's still rusty but they're got it
to fold I got a can of wd-40 and a bunch
of hammers and edges and stuff and we're
gonna see if we can't get this thing
busted down to all this part so we can
start cleaning it
[Music]
[Music]
well it took quite a bit of work and a
lot of wd-40 but we got most of stuff
off one of these pedals just will not
budge and the stem do the handlebars is
rusted on really good so I'm gonna put
this in the vise and try to get the
handlebar stem out and I'll think of
something with the rest of it look at
the cobwebs on that all right this is
not the tool for getting this part off
but it is the tool I have okay I dropped
the ball bearing casing on the ground
but luckily they're all present and
accounted for and got the fork off this
is the locking mechanism that keeps the
bike from unfolding but it won't quite
latch right there and I think that's
because the rust is built up in this
spring preventing the spring from
compressing all the way we're gonna try
oh there we go
little tippity-tap yeah we need to get
rid of all of that rust right in there
well I've got the bike mostly broken
down but that's all the time I have
right now so I'm gonna go ahead and set
this aside and pick it up just a little
bit it's another day and falls come with
the bang but we're gonna keep working on
the bike project and I've got my little
boy date with me he's rockin his car
hearts I've got the bike broke it down
to all the parts I want to save and I
need to refurbish them by getting the
rust off the the smaller stuff I can
soak in a bucket of a vapour rust and
the bigger stuff which won't fit into
the bucket I am gonna I'm gonna coat
with a layer of naval jelly to get the
rust off
[Music]
this product I'm using is called of baby
rust and I've used this before for other
projects and I really like it it's
non-toxic but you have to submerge the
rusty item in the availa rust and it's
reusable but you need a lot of it to
submerge it and some of these things
like the bike rims I'll have to rotate
and flip because I can't get it all
under under the vapor us at the same
time we'll see how that goes we're gonna
paint some of this naval jelly onto the
rusty spots here and see if that helps
yeah you brush it on well it's been
about 4 hours and you can see here we've
made a lot of progress but you need to
constantly keep reapplying the naval
jelly it kind of loses its kick after a
little bit and then you have to put some
fresh stuff on so it's taken a lot
longer than I thought but working pretty
well over here with the evapo rust we're
doing pretty well we're making progress
it's a little bit slower no but you can
see like the that stem was just
absolutely covered in rust and it's it's
coming along pretty nicely so keep
soaking I've been soaking that bicycle
and reapplying naval jelly for about
eight hours now and been shooting some
other videos while I wait and we're
losing our sunlight so I'm gonna rinse
it off and put it away
but the stuff in the vapor rust can just
sit there until I'm ready for it
but the naval jelly you don't you don't
want to leave it on for too long it gets
hardens and will leave a little pink
residue on everything
well guys it's been a couple days and
this stuff has just been sitting in the
evapo rust so let's see if we can't
clean up these bike rims and maybe just
maybe start painting that is impressive
that was solid rust look how shiny that
is
well that kickstand was just absolute
garbage nice well I've got a basket full
of these little washers and bolts and
stuff I'm gonna go ahead and soak this
in the vapor rush for a little while in
there I've got to get all the decals off
so I'm gonna take this box cutter and
see if I can't get these stickers off
well I've never used it before but I got
one of these por-15 painting kits it's
supposed to be really good for rusty
stuff painting over the top of rusty
objects though I don't know if I need
that i D rusted it pretty well but uh
paint brush cleanser degreaser some
metal prep oh and that is a very tiny
tiny can of paint that might be a
problem this tiny little cat food can is
not going to cover all the parts I need
I just have a hard time believing it
especially since they want to do two
layers and this is telling me that if
it's gonna be exposed to direct sunlight
I need a top coat for UV protection
which I don't have and it looks like I
need some sort of spray bottle so I
think I'm gonna get myself some more
paint a top coat and a spray bottle now
we're gonna deal with this once I got
all those things well fall has arrived
and so has my new can of paint
a bigger can of the paint and a big old
can of the topcoat so we're ready to get
going with this and so now I'm gonna go
and tape up the bike anything I don't
want to be covered in paint I'm gonna
tape up and we're get going
[Music]
[Music]
I didn't take this part off because this
was so rusted on I was having a hard
time getting that off but I looked down
here and this is coming out this this
little allen wrench nut is backing out
so I've got to get this off so I can
tighten that up so I have to figure out
a way I could not get this thing off
earlier and that naval jelly seems to
have done the trick and loosen that up
thank goodness I've never actually
removed this part of a bike and so I'm
watching a YouTube video on how to do it
because obviously there is something
going on here I just can't get those
crank arms off you're supposed to use an
extractor tool and sometimes you can
monkey it with a crowbar or screwdrivers
but it's just not budging probably
because of rust so I ordered a $19
extractor tool on amazon.com and it
should get here by tomorrow and I've
also noticed that this sprocket is
really bent so we're gonna see if we
can't do something about that but I'll
have to pick this up tomorrow cuz need
the tool spend a couple days and the
tool came in the mail so according to
the instructions I take this part and I
thread that on all the way
so we gonna have to not thread it on and
now we have to screw this thing in and I
think what happens is this pushes that
nut in the middle out of the hole and
then just prise it off oh that's dirty
you can see where all the begging from
trying to do this without the puller
tool just jacked up the the sprocket a
little bit so now I can get to this
thingamajiggy and get it back in and fix
that oh that's looking pretty bad inside
man that is rusted up I might want to
drop that in the vapor rust all right
Nathan you ready for the next step so
this 15 kit says I'm supposed to spray
on so the port 15 kit says I'm supposed
to put on this degreaser first which I
just dumped half of it on the ground and
then rinse everything with water and let
it dry and then I put on some metal prep
spray and do the same thing well
amazingly I think I got everything
coated with what was just left over in
the bottle but it's tearing up my hands
I think it's dissolving my skin so I
need to go wash my hands quick
all right now I gotta hit with the metal
surface treating solution let that sit
for 10-15 minutes and then I can rinse
it off well a bicycle frame is taking
its Deary time to dry I'm going through
this bucket of parts and it's been
soaking in the vapor rust and just
getting them all cleaned up all right
time to paint this thing I got a mint
I'm a little bit nervous
there's moving parts that if I coat in
paint it will ruin them so got to be
really careful and paint things
carefully
it was about an hour painting all of
this it's really finicky stuff and I was
trying to have to make a mess of it
because this stuff gets everywhere but
I'm done it looks amazing so I'm gonna
let it dry overnight I'm gonna go over
then we'll pick this up live it later
[Music]
well it's a cold wet fall day and the
heater on to try to put some warmth in
this garage I've got two coats of paint
on the bike but unfortunately because
it's only been in the 40s and 50s the
last few days it's mostly dry it just
still feels a little bit unset so I'm
going to try to heat the garage up first
and see him a couple hours of 60s and 73
temperatures can't get the paint to set
before I start assembling
I mean it's not perfect but it doesn't
look too bad
not too bad at all yeah that one's
looking good too
all right check that out that looks
pretty slick yeah that's gonna be
awesome
all right there we go one down
[Music]
here's the ball bearings that attached
the the fork for the front wheel to the
stem and we have clean those things up
and we need to lube them up alright so
when I painted the fork I painted this
part which shouldn't be painted and so I
need to come in with a little exacto
knife and clear away that paint cuz
that's interfering with the ball
bearings well this is killing my legs
bending over so I'm gonna move this up
to my workbench which I should have done
a long time ago
[Music]
hang it that axe just fell off the wall
hit knocked over my lamp knocked over my
basket full of nuts and bolts and just
spread them all over the place now I
hope I found everything but I think the
odds of that are low
[Music]
so I got a new crank arm set for this
bike and the other one was all bent up
in Scopus and they're pretty cheap I got
this on amazon.com for like 12 bucks or
something like that so we're going to
put this on this chain is supposed to be
over there
I bought some replacement pedals because
these ones are designed specifically for
folding bikes and they fold up like that
okay so that's pretty cool I thought
that would be a nice little improvement
I forgot to put that on all right take
it off
well guys I just been an hour going to
the hardware store trying to find a
replacement nut for this 8 millimeter
bolt okay this is the nut that's lost
somewhere in my garage and it goes right
there and it's what keeps the handlebars
in place but the hardware store did not
sell eight millimeter fine coarse thread
nuts and so I tried to find some other
bulbs and I got them home and they
didn't work and so I just ordered on
amazon.com
a replacement knot and it should be here
tomorrow I'm gonna go eat some dinner
take some deep cleansing breaths and
I'll show you what we got tomorrow
when that nut comes all right well guys
I got the bike fully assembled tuned up
the brakes in the gear shifter and I'm
ready to do the big reveal
they had those black rims and white
tires really pop brakes look sharp the
white grips on there the black
handlebars gloss black finish on
everything
nice wide comfortable seat you got the
shock absorbers the only original chrome
I couldn't find a replacement for that
and couldn't paint it so it's one of the
only things that stayed chrome got these
fold-in pedals and I replaced all the
quick-release bolts with these a little
bit more fancy ones work a little bit
better got one up there to the gear
shift and the rear derailleur one of the
few things I could not replace even if I
wanted to this is a only a3 geared bike
they just don't make many three geared
bikes anymore and the ones they do
aren't mini sized very often so very
hard to find those parts look at that
that looks pretty darn sharp all right
let's go check it out let's go test this
thing out it's been several years since
I've rode this thing and I've put on
about 50 pounds since then so hopefully
this thing won't won't just break
[Music]
yeah I weigh 250 pounds in six foot four
needless to say I'm a little bit big for
this bicycle but still there we go it
works well ladies and gentlemen I hope
you enjoyed this video if you would like
to see more great videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to click Subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning thanks for
watching Batman on a little bike
fat man on a little boy